هذا هو نوع الدرس الذي يرغب قلة من
الناس في تعليمه ويريد عدد أقل
أن يستخدمه في الحياة الواقعية ، إنه
الإسعافات الأولية الأساسية
لمجتمع يتعامل مع حقيقة
الحرب أخشى لأننا لسنا
مستعدين.  لست جنديًا محترفًا ولكني
أفهم أنه من الأفضل مقابلة
العدو أثناء الاستعداد وبالمهارات المناسبة
الدكتور روبرت ليم هو محارب أمريكي قديم
يعمل مع مجموعة الدعم الطبي والجراحي العالمي ،
إنه يجلب
الأطباء والجراحين إلى أوكرانيا
لتدريب المدنيين
عليه.  تبدو ممتعة الآن ولكن هذه السيناريوهات قد
تصبح قريبًا
واقعًا مدنيًا يقام في صالة ألعاب رياضية محلية
تجذب الراقصين المهندسين والمعلمين بجميع
أنواع المهن والفئات العمرية
بما في ذلك طلاب المدارس الثانوية الذين
أجبرتهم الحرب فجأة على وضع خططهم الخاصة
في الانتظار.  أعرف
متى سأدرس في المستقبل
لأنه الآن
وقت صعب ولا أعرف ما يمكن أن يكون
غدًا.
ليم هو تعليم الناس
مهارات البقاء على قيد الحياة في ساحة المعركة مثل كيفية التقديم
في  أسلوبنا أو كيفية الحفاظ على
الشخص المصاب يتنفس
مع 23 عامًا من الخبرة كجراح عسكري
، كما يقوم أيضًا بتدريب الأطباء على
الاستعداد لنوع الجروح التي نادرًا ما
تُرى في المدنيين أثناء أوقات السلم إذا
كنت في مدينة نيويورك أو لندن أو في مدينة
كبيرة أخرى  معظم الإصابات في المدينة
تكون حادة لذا فهي حادث سيارة أو
سقوط أو شيء من هذا القبيل في حين أن
معظم الإصابات في ساحة المعركة
ستكون جروحًا مخترقة
قد تصيب شريانًا أو سفينة كبيرة
وكل ذلك بجزء صغير من
الموارد  لقد اعتادوا أن يفعلوا ما في
وسعهم مع ما لديك
في أجزاء كثيرة من أوكرانيا
، أصبح من
الصعب الحصول على الإمدادات والمرافق الطبية وفي المناطق الأكثر تضرراً ،
تعمل العديد من المستشفيات الآن
في الأقبية مع المصابيح الكهربائية فقط
لتجنب جذب الروس  القنابل
الدكتورة تانيا بويتشوك هي طبيبة أمراض جلدية من
غرب أوكرانيا واحدة من عشرات المهنيين الطبيين
الذين يشحذون مهاراتهم
للمعركة في الحياة العادية لا يقدم أطباء الأمراض الجلدية
أولاً  معرف لا تتوقف عن
النزيف لا تفعل العواصف والثقب
مع وظيفتها اليومية معلقة إنها تخطط
للانضمام إلى الجيش ولن
تنتظر حتى يأتي القتال إليها ، أخطط
للذهاب إلى جبهة الحرب أصدقائي المقربون يحاربون
الآن  وأريد أن أكون هناك أيضًا
سكوت ماكلين سي إن لا فيف أوكرانيا